ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه قالت الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه انما يقوم به الاحتلال من مساس
بالمقدسات يمثل حربا شعواء على الشعب
الفلسطيني والامه العربيه وان ذلك سيشعل
الحرائق في المنطقه حسب تعبيرها وحملت
رئاسه الفلسطينيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
كامل المسؤوليه عن اي تدهور قد يقع ودعت
الى وقف ما وصفته بالعبث الذي ستكون لها
له نتائج خطيره على الجميع
وطلبت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه الاداره
الامريكيه بعدم الوقوف متفرجه على الحرائق
التي يشعلها الاحتلال في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه من جهته قال الرئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل هنيه انما
يجري في الاقصى المبارك جريمه غير مسبوقه
ولها ما بعدها الامين العام للجهاد
الاسلامي زياد النخاله قال ان على الشعب
الفلسطيني ان يكون حاضرا بكل مكوناته
للمواجهه الحتميه مع الاحتلال في الايام
القادمه على حد قوله